pourtant quelles mesures avez-vous été
associés à la campagne du candidat
emmanuel macron et est comme prestataire
ou comme salarié et quelle était la
nature de vos prestations
mais quelle base j'étais associé donc à
la campagne présidentielle du candidat
macron à partir de septembre fin
septembre octobre 2016 en tant que
bénévole dans un premier temps mais mon
rôle était dans un premier temps
d'accompagner le service d'ordre
gt gt avec monsieur benalla donc qui
était dans le service d'ordre
je recrutais notamment les bénévoles du
service d'ordre on avait fait un appel à
volontaires sur la base des listes
d'adhérents que nous avions et nous
avons ainsi recruter et former des
bénévoles pour assister le service
d'ordre lors des meetings et pour
assurer l'accueil
j'insiste sur le mot d'accueil au
quartier général de la baie groulx à
partir du moment où nous nous sommes
installés là-bas le 15 novembre 2016 je
vous remercie madame jourda oui alors là
s'était dans un premier temps vous nous
avez indiqué comme bénévole et ensuite
nous allons y voilà j'ai été prestataire
pour la république enfin en marche à
l'époque et le 1er juillet 2010 est je
suis devenu salarié de en marche
donc après la victoire présidentielle je
vous remercie madame jourda oui c'était
précisément le sens de ma question
suivante depuis quand étiez-vous
employés au sein du mouvement la
république en marche qui vous avez
recruté et quelles fonctions exercées
vous monsieur kraz donc j'ai été
présentée par monsieur benhaddad qui
avait qui étaient rentrés antérieurement
au sein du mouvement il m'a comme nous
nous connaissions depuis 2009 il l'a dit
tout à l'heure je l'est
je les rencontrais dans le cadre de sa
préparation militaire de gendarmerie et
nous nous sommes toujours suivi
amicalement il m'a proposé de rejoindre
les rendent en marche et bien sûr c'est
pas lui qui a décidé tout j'ai été
adoubé en parler les gens qui étaient
qui faisait partie du staff
voilà pour m'occuper donc mes fonctions
vous vous posiez la question de mes
fonctions pour m'occuper notamment de la
gestion des bénévoles au sein du qg de
la baie groulx qui avait pour mission
d'assurer l'accueil des gens qui sonnait
et on a eu beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
visites pendant la campagne donc assurer
l'accueil et vous et regardez si toutes
les personnes qui accédaient au qg il y
avait quelque chose à faire
jourdas alors une dernière question qui
on comprend plusieurs j'aurais souhaité
savoir dans quelles conditions vous
aviez rejoint en qualité de réserviste
le commandement militaire du palais de
l'elysée si vous aviez été recommandée
ou appuyer pour cette affectation
ensuite combien de fois vous aviez été
convoqué en tant que réserviste à
l'elysée pour quelles missions et si
votre hiérarchie au sein du mouvement de
la république en marche était informé de
votre emploi en tant que réserviste à
l'elysée beaucoup de beaucoup de
questions je vous écoute allez-y donc je
vais essayer de répondre à toutes ces
questions en formulant une réponse
globale
donc je rencontre la première fois le
général bio-farina au mois de septembre
2010 est sur la recommandation
d'alexandre benalla puisqu'il y avait
comme projet de monter une structure de
réserve au palais de l'élysée structure
de réserve donc qui doit permettre de
gonfler les effectifs des gardes
républicains qui sont des militaires
d'activé à chaque fois en fait qu'un
réserviste intervient il est en trinôme
avec de garde
si vous comprenez le sens de ma réponse
donc le but c'était de pouvoir gonfler
les effectifs sur des sur des événements
particuliers tels que les journées du
patrimoine mais aussi au quotidien
puisque les effectifs
fournit de la garde républicaine sont
des fois j'ai pas dire insuffisant mais
là ça permettait d'avoir un peu plus de
volume
je crois que monsieur benallal a dit
tout à l'heure tous les palais de la
république ont des réservistes notamment
le sénat vous avez des réservistes qui
viennent du 2e régiment d'infanterie
donc là le but était de proposer sous
forme d'appel à volontaires aux
réservistes du 1er régiment d'infanterie
de venir rejoindre le palais de l'elysée
et avec une particularité c'était que
cette mission élyséenne devait être
exclusive de toute autre pour des
raisons de confidentialité
donc je rencontre le général bio farina
nous discutons autour de ce projet il me
confie donc la mission de monter cette
structure de réservistes mais moi à
cette époque là je suis réservistes dans
la départementale 1 er ghn région de
gendarmerie de haute normandie
donc il a fallu faire transférer mon
dossier ce qui a pris un peu de temps
puisque l'administration militaire et
prend son temps pour faire les choses
dans l'ordre on va dire pour ne pas
précipiter les choses
j'ai commencé ma première journée de
réserve au palais de l'elysée le 10
novembre 2017
j'ai fait le 10 et le 11 novembre qui
étaient des journées de découverte on va
dire les plus exhaustive possible du
palais et des services pour bien
imprégné ensuite nous avons reçu des
candidats réservistes dont qui jeûnaient
du 1er régiment d'infanterie et qu'ils
étaient intéressés par cette mission
donc ils ont eu plusieurs filtres un
premier filtre avec moi et un autre
officier donc du sc eux le sc eux c'est
le service de contrôle des entrées qui
dépend du commandement militaire
et la mission principale de toute façon
de ses réservistes et de travailler au
profit du service de contrôle des
entrées premier filtre ensuite le
deuxième filtre une validation par le
général bio-farina lui-même qui étant
l'autorité hiérarchique à plus haut tu
veux connaître tous les gens qui vont
travailler pour le commandement
militaire